Söre ich başlatte, Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ucak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ich bin einverstanden Doktor, danke schön.
Ja danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Ich werde Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen bevor Sie über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen. Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja ich verstehe.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Petra Lösa.
Frau Lösa, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 5 und 5, 50 Jahre alt Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
11.2.1970
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
74 Kilogramm.
Ok, danke für die Informationen. Frau Lösa, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Doktor, ich fühle mich sehr nervös.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden Frau Lösa?
Seit etwa 3 oder bis 4 Monaten fühle ich mich dieser Beschwerden.
Ok, seit 3 bis 4 Monaten fühlen Sie sich nervös. Also meinen Sie unruhig?
Ja, ja. Entschuldigung?
Unruhig meinen Sie?
Ja, ja. Ich bin innerlich unruhig. Fast schon hübelig. Und merke, dass ich öfter Herzrasen habe.
Ok. Frau Lösa, also darf ich fragen, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen? Besonders schiktrischen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt Doktor. Nein.
Ok, alles klar. Frau Lösa, darf ich fragen, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist nicht gut.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen? Ich meine unwillkürlich?
Ja, ja. Ich habe in nur einem Monat ungefähr 7 Kilo abgenommen.
Alles klar. Frau Lösa, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie Hautfarbe oder Haut verändern gerne?
Wie zum Beispiel feuchte Haut oder Nägelveränderung oder Haarausfall haben?
Ja Doktor. Dazu kommt, dass meine Nägel beruhig geworden sind und mir vermehrt, die Haare ausfallen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich verstehe. Und auch haben Sie feuchte Haut bemerkt?
Ja, ja. Richtig.
Ok. Alles klar.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich ungefähr 7 Kilo abgenommen habe, obwohl ich nicht mehr aus einer Diät gemacht habe.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Appetitlosigkeit haben. Ist das richtig oder?
Ein bisschen. Ich esse gut gegessen. Aber ich habe ungefähr einen Monat ungefähr 7 Kilo abgenommen.
Alles klar. Ich habe verstanden.
Haben Sie Zittern in den Händen? Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ok. Frau Lösa, haben Sie eine Vergrößerung am Hals bemerkt?
Bei mir sind diese Beschwerden nicht ausgefallen, nein.
Es gibt keine Vergrößerung am Hals, ja?
Ja, ich habe keine Bemerkungen. Aber keine Ahnung, ob es eine Vergrößerung ist oder nicht.
Ich habe keine Bemerkungen.
Verstanden. Leiden Sie unter Schweißausbrüchen?
Ich schwitze sehr stark, auch wenn es gar nicht heiss ist.
Ok. Also Sie haben auch etwas Interessant.
Ja, richtig.
Also Empfindlichkeit gegen Hitze, ja?
Außerdem habe ich nach Schweiß gegen diese Beschwerden nicht gut geschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Durchschlafen, ja. Wegen Schwitzen.
Frau Lösa, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stürmgang?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Oder ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Fühlen Sie sich fieberig? Also ich meine, ja Sie haben eine Empfindlichkeit gegen Hitze, aber haben Sie Fieber oder Schütterfrost, meine ich?
Ich habe das Fieber nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, nein.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Bei mir sind diese Beschwerden nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft gegen 3x Covid.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit besonders eine Reise ins Ausland gemacht?
Vor zwei Monaten gehe ich mit meiner Familie nach Schweiz.
Frau Lösa, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe chronischen Rückschmerzen, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Es ist sehr lange, ungefähr acht oder zehn Jahre.
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ja, ich nehme eine Tablette Diclofenac gegen diese Beschwerden, bei Bedarf.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich habe nicht erinnern, Doktor, nein.
Haben Sie eine Medikamentenliste dabei?
Jetzt nicht, aber vielleicht kennen meine Hausarztin meine Wege oder andere Medikamente.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Frau Schüller.
Ok, ich werde Ihren Hausärztin kontaktieren, ja. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Frau Lösa, sonst noch haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe auch seit langem eine chronische Nasennebenhochentzündung.
Seit wann haben Sie dieses Problem?
Seit vier Jahren.
Und nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen ein?
Ja, ich nehme dafür ein Nasenspray ein, aber ich weiß den Namen leider nicht mehr.
Ok, kein Problem.
Benutzen Sie diese Nasenspray regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Bei Bedarf so ein bis zwei Mal pro Woche.
Und das war's?
Ja, das war's.
Frau Lösa, besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, Doktor. Ich besuche regelmäßig meinen Frauenarzt jeden zwei Monate.
Und alles in Ordnung?
Ja, alles in Ordnung.
Und wann war Ihre letzte Monatblutung?
Es war sehr lange Zeit. Ich habe nicht erinnert, aber ungefähr vor 20 Jahren.
Sie sind jetzt 55 Jahre alt, richtig?
Nein, nein, vor fünf Jahren.
Fünf Jahre, ok, alles klar.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, vor etwa zehn Jahren hatte ich beim Skifahren einen Unfall.
Dabei habe ich mir den rechten Knochen gebrochen.
Was meint ihr damit? Knochen oder Knochen?
Knochen.
Knochen, der rechte Knochen.
Ok, außer Knochen oder innen Knochen?
Innen Knochen. Bei mir wurde eine Operation gemacht.
Ok, und sonst?
Vor vier Jahren hatte ich eine Schleimbaute entzündet, am rechten Ellenbogen.
Und Sie hatten eine Operation, richtig?
Ja, ja.
Ok, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten noch irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Ich habe vergessen, Doktor, ich habe seit etwa vier Jahren eine Fetstoffweichzerstörung.
Und nehme dafür Simvostatin.
Seit?
Entschuldigung bitte.
Seit fünf Jahren?
Seit etwa vier Jahren.
Vier Jahren.
Aber ich bin mir bei der genauen Dosierung nicht ganz sicher.
Aber ich nehme es abends.
Ok, also leiden Sie an erhöhten Blutfettwerte?
Ja, ja.
Ok, und ich glaube Sie nehmen keine anderen Medikamente ein, außer genannten?
Und haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente oder Pflanzen oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ich reagiere allergisch auf keine Medikamente oder Pflanzen, nein.
Sie haben keine Allergie, richtig?
Ja, ja, ich habe keine Allergie.
Ok, Frau Löser, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Ich habe nicht geraucht, nein.
Das freut mich. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ich trinke selten Alkohol, aber ich nehme ein Glas Bier.
Oder ein Ferain.
Ok, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen, Doktor.
Super. Frau Löser, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdurung oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja Doktor, in meiner Familie gibt es schwere Erkrankungen.
Mein Vater musste einmal wiederbleiben.
Wiederbleiben werden wegen eines Herzstillstands.
Er lebt jetzt im Altenheim.
Aber es gibt momentan kein Problem, richtig?
Ja, momentan kein Problem.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist mit 65 Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Mein Beileid, Frau Löser.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, aber sie sind gesund.
Ihre Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Ein Sohn und zwei Töchter.
Alle sind gesund.
Super. Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Landschaftsgärtnerin.
Und leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Familie.
Alles klar.
Frau Löser, das war meine Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Doktor, was habe ich?
Ich bin innerlich unruhig.
Ich bin sehr unruhig.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Frau Löser, machen Sie sich bitte um.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung, hierher zu kommen.
Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus.
Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen.
Ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit Schilddrüssen haben.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Schilddrüssenüberfunktion.
Deswegen werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Ich habe viel Angst.
Es könnte sein, dass ich verrückt bin.
Nein, kann jedenfalls.
Frau Löser, Sie haben wahrscheinlich ein Problem mit Schilddrüssen.
Dieses Problem kann solche Beschwerden verursachen.
Mit einer Medikamentösertherapie werden Sie sich wieder gut fühlen.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Sehr gerne.
Ich warte auf Sie.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über Sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja.
Danke.
Frau Petra Löser ist 55 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und 7 kg schwer.
Frau Löser stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 3 bis 4 Monaten bestehender Nervosität vor.
Die Patientin berichtete über Trachycardie, Allopäsee, Nägelbruch, Feuchtehaut, Hyperhydrose, nächtliche Hyperhydrose, Hitze in Toiletten, Schmerzen, Schmerzen.
Hitze in Toleranz und Gewichtsabnahme von 7 kg innerhalb von einem Monat.
Die Fragen nach Inapetens, Dyspne und Tussis und Vergrößerung im Halsbereich und Wärtiger wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen.
Die Patientin sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und 3 mal gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
Sie habe mit ihrer Familie vor 2 Monaten eine Reise nach Schweiz gemacht.
Sie besuchte ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig jedes 2 Monate und letzte Monatblutung war vor 5 Jahren.
Anvorerkrankungen nannte sie seit 8 bis 10 Jahren bestehende chronische Lumbargie, seit 4 Jahren bestehende Sinusitis und seit 4 Jahren bestehende Hyperlipidemie.
Sie nehme Diclofenac bei Bedarf, Nasenspray 1 bis 2 Mal pro Woche bei Bedarf und Simvastatin abends ein.
Die Dosierung von Medikamenten sollte geklärt werden.
Vor 10 Jahren habe sie sich beim Skifahrenunfall rechtseitige Innenknochenfraktur zugezogen, die operativ behandelt worden sei.
Vor 4 Jahren sei sie wegen einer Bursitis am rechten Ellenbogen operiert worden.
Allergiegeschichte wurde verneint, Nikotinkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint und sie trinke ein Glas Bier am Wochenende.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass der Vater an Assistolie gelitten und hatte eine Resuscitation.
Die Mutter sei mit 65 Jahren an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Sie habe eine Schwester, die gesund sei. Die Patientin sei verheiratet, habe einen Sohn und zwei Töchter, die gesund seien und die Patientin wohne mit ihrer Familie.
Sie sei Landschaftsgärtnerin von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Hyperarthriose aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter Nervosität, Tachikardie, Gewichtsabnahme von 7 kg innerhalb von einem Monat, Allopäie, Nägelveränderungen, Hyperhydrose, nächtliche Hyperhydrose.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Hyperthyriose.
Als Differenzia-Diagnosen kommen Zephygus, Carcinom, Morbus Hodgkin, aber es gibt keine Heißvergrößerung.
Die Metabolischen Krankheiten wie Diabetes mellitus
Zunächst würde ich bei der Patientin eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Halsvergrößerung, Hautfarbeveränderungen, vergrößerte Lymphknoten, Nägelveränderungen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CRP, BSK, TSH, T3, T4, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten, Blutzucker, Herzenzime bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Thyroid-Ultra-Sonographie durchführen, um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Danach würde ich eine Feinnadelbiopsie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen.
Zusätzlich würde ich eine Thyroid-Synthographie verlassen, um die möglichen Knoten zu beurteilen, ob die kalten oder heißen Knoten sind.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientinstation aufnehmen.
Ich würde die Patientin einen venösen Zugang legen und Flüssigkeitzufuhr, Metamizol, Opilturacil, Beta-Blocker verbreiten.
Danach würde ich ein endokrinologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, ich würde in diesem Fall ein Blutbild bestimmen lassen. Welches Blutbild? Kleines oder großes? Und warum?
Ich würde ein kleines Blutbild bestimmen lassen, also besonders ein Lykocytin-Zahl, um die Thyroiditis auszuschließen.
Und ich würde kontrollieren, ob die Patientin Anämie hat.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie möchten ein Sündungsdiagnostil aussehen, würde ich ein großes Blutbild bestimmen lassen, wenn Sie keine Sündungsdenken, kleines Blutbild bestimmen lassen.
In diesem Fall möchten Sie ein chirurgisches Konzil?
Ein chirurgisches Konzil würde sinnvoll sein. Bei diesen Patienten können wir eine chirurgische Therapie benutzen.
Zuerst können wir die medikamentöse Therapie veranlassen, aber wenn wir keine positiven Ergebnisse haben, dann können wir bei den Patienten eine operative Behandlung veranlassen.
In welcher Situation empfehlen Sie den Patienten eine Operation?
Wenn wir keine Antworten mit dieser medikamentösen Therapie haben, dann empfehle ich eine operative Therapie.
In diesem Fall denken Sie ein Thyroid-Karzinom?
Zuerst müssen wir eine Thyroid-Synthographie durchführen, um die möglichen Knoten zu beurteilen.
Wenn wir kalte Knoten feststellen können, dann würde ich eine Karzinom denken und würde ich eine Fein-Nadel-Biopsie durchführen, um die genaue Pathologie zu bestätigen.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde in diesem Fall eine Synthographie durchführen. Können Sie uns die Thyroid-Synthographie aufklären?
Herr Oberst, ich würde Sie gerne über die Thyroid-Synthographie aufklären.
Die Thyroid-Synthographie ist eine Untersuchung, mit der wir die Tumore oder metabolische Veränderungen bei Thyroid zu beurteilen.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die maligne Erkrankungen oder andere Knoten genau zu beurteilen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung verabreichen wir die Patienten ein leichtes radioaktives Mittel.
Dann warten wir für etwa eine Stunde. Dann machen wir mit Hilfe einer Gamakamera die Bilder der Schilddrüse.
Dann stellen wir die Bilder.
Bei dieser Untersuchung können wir die Knoten genau beurteilen, ob sie kalte oder heiße Knoten sind.
Bei der kalten Knoten machen wir eine Feinnadelbiopsik.
Herr Kollegen, was bedeutet kalte Knoten oder weiße Knoten?
Wenn die Durchblutung von Knoten vermindert ist, sehen wir heiße Knoten.
Bei der Synthographie-Methode legen die radioaktiven Mittel in den heißen Knoten mehr als in den kalten Knoten.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Untersuchung?
Nach der Untersuchung soll die Patientin viel zu viel trinken um die radioaktiven Mittel schnell auszuscheiden.
Und?
Und häufig auf die Toilette gehen.
Ich habe nur eine Grundlegende Kenntnis mit diesem Fall.
Was empfehlen Sie?
Ich empfehle die Patienten vielleicht für ein paar Tage mit den Verwandten nicht kontaktieren.
Wie viele Tage kontaktieren Sie nicht?
Ich würde sagen zwei Tage.
Oder drei.
Oder drei, ok.
In diesem Fall würden Sie eine Zonographie?
Ja, also Theroid-Zonographie ist sinnvoll um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Ok, Herr Kollegen, bitte gehen Sie auf unser Infodisk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat. Ich weiß nicht ob positiv oder?
Ja, danke Herr Oberst. Das ist sehr nett von Ihnen. Danke.
Ja, die Zonographie ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Wenn man sagt, dass der Knoten-Monoton kalt oder warm ist, muss man das beantworten.
Sondern es gibt keine Zerrung.
Und weil die Radiostreifen gegeben werden, müssen die Patienten ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Oder sie müssen nicht in der Wohnung im Krankenhaus sein.
Um keine Radiostreifen zu vergeben.
Oder sie müssen nicht in der Gesellschaft verwendet werden.
Ja, es ist ein sehr wichtiger Radiostreifen.
Aber sie sagen Radiostreifen.
War das auch in der Türkei?
War das in Deutschland?
Ja, in Deutschland.
Woher fliegt das?